[Musica]
distrofia muscolare fibrosi cistica
emofilia talassemia varie forme di
cecità sono solo l'inizio di una lunga
lista di malattie che ancora rappresenta
una sfida enorme per la medicina
stiamo parlando di malattie genetiche e
quindi di quelle malattie che sono
causate da alterazioni del dna e che
quindi potrebbero essere potenzialmente
curate se avessimo a disposizione degli
strumenti che ci permettono di arrivare
al dna dove alterato e modificarlo
ripararlo e correggerlo tuttavia la
sfida è ancora lunga il dna è una
molecola che costituita da una serie di
molecole di nucleotidi basi che possiamo
rappresentare come lettere lettere che
si dispongono a maniera molto ordinata e
precisa a costituire la doppia elica e
questo ordine e deve essere mantenuto
qualsiasi piccola alterazione che
costituita la non sostituzione da una
integrazione da una duplicazione poi
generare delle conseguenze drammatiche e
quindi deve malattie molto gravi
quando nel 2000 nel 1950 wolf creek ci
dissero appunto che questa la struttura
del dna costituita da nucleotidi da
questo ordine perfetto
si pensava che l'obiettivo di poter
riscrivere dna quindi modificarlo con
una tecnica che adesso chiamiamo di
editing genomico potesse essere a
portata di mano
in realtà l'obiettivo era molto più
complesso e già i primi esperimenti ci
dissero che era molto difficile questo
obiettivo da raggiungere
tuttavia dopo circa 30 anni è stato
fatto un altro passo avanti piccolo
molto importante in cui si è visto e
queste sono osservazioni biologiche che
quando il dna la doppia elica viene
tagliata da reagenti chimici o da per
esempio da attività fisiche quello che
si ottiene è una modifica del dna quindi
proprio quello che si tiene si cerca di
fare con l'editing genomico e quindi qui
venne un'ispirazione a tutti i
ricercatori che se riuscissimo a creare
delle forbici molecolari quindi delle
forbici che riusciamo a programmare per
arrivare sul punto in cui il dna
alterato potremmo ottenere le modifiche
che possono portare alla cura di queste
malattie che sono ancora orfane che non
hanno una cura
tuttavia anche questo obiettivo è stato
veramente difficile da raggiungere e
stiamo parlando di un'altra trentina
d'anni fino a che stiamo parlando negli
anni recenti nel 2012 viene fatta una
scoperta che è letteralmente
rivoluzionato il mondo delle
biotecnologie e non solo
stiamo parlando di una molecola che si
chiama chris parkas 9 ed è una forbice
molecolare finalmente una forbice in
grado di tagliare il dna in punti dove
noi possiamo portarla in maniera precisa
per generare quelle modifiche che
possono portare alla cura di malattie
questa molecola è un amore fra di
origine batterica
infatti noi tra gli interpreti gli
attori principali della scoperta di
questa molecola abbiamo lo yogurt lo
yogurt è un alimento che tutti
conosciamo
altra gli ingredienti principali batteri
e batteri come tutti gli esseri viventi
sono molto suscettibili da infezioni
quindi quando un gruppo di ricercatori
stava studiando come aumentare la
produzione dello yogurt quindi aumentare
la difesa dei batteri si sono accorti
che i batteri
in realtà hanno una maniera per
difendersi dalle infezioni e questo
meccanismo legato ad una molecola che
crisp al cas 9 e questa molecola
funziona proprio come forbice molecolare
quindi quando i batteri vengono
attaccati dei virus
questi batteri si difendono con una
forbice molecolare ed ecco che è
arrivata finalmente la forbice a questo
punto il trasferimento alle cellule
ovani è stato abbastanza rapido è stato
sufficiente riprogrammare chris parkas 9
portarla sul dna dove ci sono mutazioni
per portare la correzione che da tanto
tempo stavamo cercando di ottenere
questa scoperta non poteva lasciarmi
indifferente
dopo una carriera spesa tra dna
ingegneria genetica e virus quindi
immediatamente abbiamo preso questa
molecola con il mio laboratorio
all'università di trento e l'abbiamo
provata delle nostre cellule ed è stata
un'emozione incredibile trovare che
finalmente abbiamo una molecola che ci
permette di correggere alterazioni
genetiche
tuttavia i primi esperimenti ci hanno
anche rivelato che questa molecola e dei
difetti ha dei difetti molto gravi e
questi sono che oltre a modificare
vienna in punti voluti genera altre
alterazioni ed ovviamente non possiamo
pensare di curare una malattia
generandone altre e quindi ci siamo
messi subito al lavoro abbiamo pensato
che dovevamo riuscire a modificare
questa proteina e renderla più precisa
la nostra considerazione per affrontare
questo problema scientifico è stato che
chris parkas 9 alla proteina di origine
batterica e i batteri sono molto diversi
dalle cellule umane sono cellule molto
più semplici e quindi la nostra
intuizione è stata che forse dovevamo
spingere
una proteina batterica come chris parkas
9 a funzionare in celle più complesse
tuttavia le cellule umane sono difficili
da utilizzare in laboratorio e quindi la
nostra scelta andata verso un'altra
cellula un altro tipo cellulare come il
lievito il lievito paradossalmente molto
più simile alla cellula umana
stiamo parlando del lievito dire stesso
ingrediente che noi utilizziamo per fare
il pane o per fare la birra il lievito
il laboratorio si presenta così questa
una piastra di cellule di lievito che
stanno crescendo felicemente e si
presentano in questo caso queste colonne
di lievito con due colori un colore
bianco è un colore rosso e questo è
dovuto al fatto che noi prima di
lavorare e di cercare di trovare una
variante di canove più precisa le
abbiamo ingegnerizzate abbiamo fatto sì
che le cellule bianche ecc indicassero
quando questa proteina cas 9 stava
tagliando in maniera non corretta quelle
rosse invece ci indicavano che cas 9 era
precisa e quindi è stato sufficiente
creare migliaia migliaia i tipi diversi
di cas 9 delle variazioni diversi di cas
9 inserirebbe dentro queste cellule e
poi andare a selezionare tutte le
colonie rosse abbiamo scartato quelle
bianche e dentro le colonie rosse
abbiamo trovato finalmente una casa 9
che tagliava in maniera perfetta
quindi abbiamo lasciato che fosse il
lievito stesso a dirci quale fosse una
variante più precisa questo è il primo
esperimento che abbiamo ottenuto in
laboratorio su cellule umane quello che
vedesse sulla sinistra
e i tagli di kras 9 originale quindi la
cas 9 iniziale e tutte le righe che voi
vedete sono tutti gli errori che fa cup
9 tutte le lettere sono le lettere che
ha riconosciuto per
sulla destra era nostra valiante
l'abbiamo chiamata evoca 9 perché è una
variante più evoluta ed è evoluta perché
come vedete fa un taglio preciso e il
foglio e bianco
i risultati che ci ha dato e di una
totale assenza di errori quindi
finalmente abbiamo a disposizione una
molecola che in grado di riparare il dna
e lo fa in un punto preciso riusciamo a
programmarlo andare solo in un punto ed
evitare che faccia altri tagli quindi
finalmente abbiamo disposizioni una
molecola che potrà essere utilizzata per
curare malattie che ad oggi non abbiamo
ancora di cui abbiamo trovato una cura
ma gli esseri viventi tutti gli esseri
viventi sono caratterizzati da verona
molecola dna quindi potenzialmente tutti
gli esseri viventi possono essere
modificati le piante gli animali e ci
sono già progetti in corso per
modificare animali in italia abbiamo un
gruppo di ricerca che è molto avanti
nella modifica delle zanzare che portano
il plasmodio della malaria quindi
possano bloccare le zanzare ed
eventualmente eradicare la malaria ma ci
sono dei progetti che vanno ancora di
più
oltre al limite e quindi ci sono dei
progetti che er esempio finanziati negli
stati uniti che prevedono la
d'estinzione dei mammut quindi
modificando gli elefanti potenzialmente
possiamo distinguere mammut e e
riportare sulla terra
ma tornando a noi
ecco in via mente il queste antipodi
sorpasso del limite ha ispirato anche
case cinematografiche e quindi la
possibilità di generare animali
mostruosi ma stiamo parlando soltanto
della fantasia di un limite che
ovviamente non conosciamo ancora
tornando a noi come possiamo vedere
l'applicazione di questa proteina
negli umani beh possiamo pensare che in
futuro potremmo progettare i bambini in
maniera tale che possano rispondere a
diverse esigenze
quindi possiamo pensare a bambini che
possano essere progettati per il colore
della pelle il colore degli occhi o
pensare a un colore di capelli diverso
ho visto che la nostra conoscenza sui
geni si va sempre più avanti in teoria
possiamo anche pensare con giorno
potremo progettare i bambini per la loro
intelligenza per il loro carattere opere
allora predisposizione alle malattie
mandando un futuro più vicino
probabilmente questa tecnologia potrà
essere utilizzata per eliminare quei
difetti genetici che portano i bambini
ad avere malattie devastanti
quindi potremmo pensare probabilmente in
un futuro di eradicare malattie
genetiche molto gravi e quindi
ovviamente stiamo parlando di sorpassare
i limiti e come in tutte queste
condizioni in questi tuazioni è
necessario che ci confrontiamo e che
questi tipi di argomenti escano da uno
stretto ambito scientifico e tecnico e
vadano abbracciare altri settori della
società
stiamo parlando di risvolti bioetici di
cui abbiamo bisogno di parlare e di
discutere ed è importante che l'opinione
pubblica sia coinvolta in queste nuove
tecnologie
perché questa è una tecnologia che non
si fermerà andrà a impattare la società
in passato nella storia dell'uomo ci
sono stati altri cambiamenti epocali
importanti per esempio la scoperta di
antibiotici di vaccini ha cambiato
enormemente l'umanità e così crisp al
cas 9 probabilmente cambierà l'umanità e
vede abbiamo un futuro di fronte che non
conosciamo ancora non conosciamo ancora
bene
e che dobbiamo appunto continuare a
discuterne e parlarne
il nostro mondo intorno si sta già
modificando con chris par
abbiamo già le prime modifiche degli
animali
abbiamo la modifica degli elefanti ma
abbiamo la modifica di embrioni o
embrioni umani
quindi stiamo decisamente vivendo ora
chris paul revolution
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]